who is the mystery caller the mystery
cause our friend ESPN NFL reporter Jeff
darling okay a little victory lap for
Jeff Darlington ESPN NFL reporter who
told us a couple of weeks ago that Tom
was gonna be leaving he would be shocked
if he stayed and also he said Dan don't
rule out the Tampa Bay Buccaneers as I
laughed and scoffed and Paulie put up
$500 bed for Jeff Darlington for the
Jimmy V foundation I believe and Jeff
joining us now congratulations Jeff yes
no no I'm not calling for a victory lap
I'm just calling as part of the
donations Department for the foundation
letting you know that we take all major
credit cards
Apple pay yes blow Jeff can I then mow
you I'm ready to go I'm ready to help
the cause so when did you know it that
he wasn't coming back yeah I mean when I
said that I would be shocked I I mean
look here's the thing
I was coming from a very sincere place
when I said that and when the context
that I had added on the show is that
there are still people around town
though that think that he if you were to
go into Bill Belichick's office and
belcheck laid out this master plan that
they wouldn't surprise despite the fact
that Brady himself is only saying I'm
not going back so I lay at that context
because you know I look I think we were
all in the same kind of level of
disbelief that Tom would leave the
Patriots but but quite frankly you
wouldn't even those close to him aren't
necessarily believing him it's tough to
just sit there and say he's not going
back but you know at that point after
kind of hearing it for longer than a
month that he wasn't going back I was
finally to the point where you know what
he's not going back what do you think
the main like if you were gonna trying
to pin down the one reason why he wasn't
going back
Oh fun you want to have fun and and that
can be a matter of running away from
something that was no longer necessarily
fun and maybe chasing something that
that would be he's not ready to retire
from football
yes the relationship between me and Bill
Belichick restrained but I don't think
that it's necessarily critical to say
that that was the entire reason it was
also just about a new challenge and kind
of the invigorating himself and and I
think it can be both to be honest do you
think Edelman is in Tampa next year I
don't think so like I can't imagine Bill
Belichick like yeah let me go and send
some peaches to Glen a long time ladies
what a Super Bowl and make me look so
stupid I just don't I mean look at that
totally me just kind of speculating but
why would you do that I'm right there
with you unless he goes that guy's gonna
be 34 and he's been banged up
maybe I can get something and maybe
they'll take him off my hands as well
yeah yeah no doubt I mean like you kind
of go across the board with that like
like Gronkowski's still still properties
the of the Patriots like why wouldn't
the Bucs go try to offer something for
that too but but but to that point like
I just can't see Belichick being like
yeah let me go ahead and help out this
cause this seems like a really smart
thing for me to do final 30 seconds who
do you think the quarterback is going to
be in New England
I actually I could see that I'm trying
to make student work I know that's again
probably pretty surprising but I could
see them really feeling like they're
going to go in there and prove their
point with Stidham so you know I you
know Andy Dalton certainly one of the
products out there but the possibilities
but but I think this is a team that will
look towards Stidham and try to give him
a chance
yeah Paulie Jeff you want to go double
or nothing on some Aussies befall
tonight Thank You Geoff well done that's
Jeff Darlington
yes pian